et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent Marc Angeli bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés de la
Corse du Sud président du groupe horizon
à l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Julien Lecuyer de la voiture de la fête
du Nord tout à fait bonjour Julien
bonjour monsieur bonjour on va parler ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée évidemment le
remarquant Jane c'est une journée sous
tension qui s'annonce aujourd'hui du
côté du Palais Bourbon il n'y aura pas
de vote sur la progression de la
retraite à 64 ans l'opposition
n'a-t-elle pas raison de crier au déni
de démocratie l'opposition je crois est
un exercice de style
et dans l'abus l'abus verbale la butte
communication
je vous son rôle d'opposition on peut
pas dire qu'on n'avait pas prévenu les
choses ont été dites clairement il y a
une Constitution il y a un règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a eu un vote
la semaine dernière en commission des
affaires sociales d'ailleurs la vérité
c'est que plus personne ne comprend rien
à ce qui se passe mais je vais essayer
de vous dire ce qui se passe
l'opposition savait que cette loi
n'était pas une loi qui était
toléré par les textes constitutionnels
elle a quand même voulu aller au bout en
assemblant tous les contraires le groupe
iode qui porte la nupesse le RN et au
final l'opposition elle s'est fait
prendre à son propre piège c'est celui
de l'absurdité de la démarche qui était
la sienne qui n'était qu'une démarche
politiqueienne et de communication mais
ce qui a pas quand même un problème
d'image là-dedans c'est-à-dire que les
Français vont s'apercevoir encore
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas eu de vote
sur la réforme des retraites alors vous
allez me répondre il y a eu 49-3 il y a
eu la motion de censure derrière mais
concrètement il n'y a pas eu toujours il
y a toujours pas eu de vote sur la
réforme en elle-même il y a eu les votes
je vous répond la même chose et a eu des
votes il y a eu des votes à l'Assemblée
au Sénat il y a eu un vote encore la
semaine dernière sauf à faire mine
d'ignorer que l'article premier qui
voulait rétablir la retraite à 62 ans a
été rejetée par la commission des
affaires sociales et avoir la démocratie
sélective et se dire qu'en réalité bien
la Constitution c'est qu'un morceau de
papier et se dire que le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale en réalité on peut
s'asseoir dessus
ça va créer un précédent en fin de en
tout cas l'opposition prend comme tel le
fait que il y ait eu rejet par exemple
de des amendements que qu'il y ait Brown
privé la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale à d'ores et déjà dit que elle
n'accepterait pas ses amendements ça
crée un précédent dangereux dit
l'opposition pour le fût de la fusion
d'activité de du Parlement le précédent
dangereux qu'aurait constitué
éventuellement le vote de cette loi
inapplicable qui aurait été censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel ça vous dit
pas quelque chose de plus grave encore
en réalité les oppositions aujourd'hui
elles auraient voulu voter un texte dans
tel SAV qu'il ne pouvait pas être à un
moment promulgué pour des raisons
constitutionnelles c'est à dire que
admettons que la loi soit votée par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
et que les deux chambres se mettent
d'accord ces signes du Conseil
constitutionnel censure c'est dangereux
c'est un jeu dangereux nous sommes dans
un système de parlementarisme
rationalisé vous parlez de la motion de
censure mais je vous rappelle tout de
même que le gouvernement lorsqu'il l'a
déclenche un 49-3 il engage ça
responsabilité l’assemblée nationale
peut le renverser
un déni de démocratie et d'ailleurs
c'est passé à 9 mois près la dernière
fois et d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu hier
dès l'annonce faite par la présidente de
l'Assemblée
une nouvelle motion de censure donc moi
je la craignais aujourd'hui ou pas moi
je respecte toujours la démocratie il va
falloir convaincre les parlementaires de
ne pas être majoritaires pour la voter
vous avez déjà peut-être eu des
entretiens avec les élus corses à ce
propos
je les ai vu hier je crois qu'on en
parlera peut-être après mais je ne sais
pas ce que feront les les élus de mon
territoire qui siège à tous les trois au
groupe liotes
ils feront ce qu'ils veulent hier on a
eu une réunion qui s'est plutôt bien
passée même si on a des divergences
parfois entre nous mais ils feront ce
qu'ils veulent enfin par le passé vous
lui avez quand même aimablement rappelé
que si le gouvernement tombait il
pouvait qu'il y ait des répercussions
sur les négociations en Corse j'ai dit
quelque chose qui me paraissait un peu
frappé du coin du bon sens si vous avez
approché ah oui mais de toute façon
aujourd'hui on peut plus rien dire dans
ce pays je m'aperçois quand même que dès
qu'on essaye de dire quelque chose
même en y mettant les formes ce que je
m'efforce de faire tout le temps ça
provoque des élans des catastrophistes
et assez excessif la gauche
la gauche entend se faire entendre
jusqu'au bout aujourd'hui malgré le
rejet de l'abrogation de la retraite à
64 ans vous redoutez une journée tendue
dans l'hémicycle elle va être très tendu
et il faut garder son calme et il faut
il faut s'en tenir quand même à deux
choses c'est le respect de l'institution
de son règlement intérieur qui a quand
même été un peu secoué depuis un an avec
quelques incidents en séance et puis
respect vis-à-vis des Français on peut
avoir de fortes divergences mais avoir
des débats construits mais à quoi vous
vous attendez comment votre groupe s'y
prépare comment la majorité s'y prépare
en imagine que vous en avez aussi parlé
qu'au en berger nous allons soutenir nos
idées comme nous l'avons fait depuis le
début et puis ensuite vous savez très
bien ce qui va se passer le petit livre
de règlement va être brandi à mon avis
quelques centaines de fois ce matin vous
allez avoir des prélèvements du
spectacle c'est ça que vous regrettez
mais je pense pas que ça serve forcément
la démocratie parlementaire lorsque les
choses sont aussi excessives vous savez
je crois en cette adage tout ce qui est
excessif est insignifiant vous attendez
à des débats qui vont durer combien
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas quelle est la stratégie du groupe
liotte c'est lui qui décide c'est le
rapporteur qui décide de retirer ou pas
le texte on peut aller au bout du texte
parce que je vous rappelle quand même
que le texte peut être voté c'est ce qui
a été aller au bout du texte oh moi je
ne souhaite rien moi je souhaite que je
souhaiterais j'aimerais bien que
l'Assemblée nationale soit respectée et
qu'elle donne une image davantage
respectable à celles et ceux qui
regarderont ce qui se passerait ce que
ça ne risque pas quand même d'altérer
profondément les relations au Parlement
on a déjà senti des répercussions de du
débat autour de l'article 40 de la
Constitution au travers de la commission
qui serait qui s'est réunissent et ces
derniers jours sur la proposition de loi
sur les déserts médicaux on se revoit on
se renvoie la balle est-ce que ça risque
pas de continuer comme ça cette
guéguerre
nous sommes dans une majorité relative
il n'y a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un précédent il y avait
pas eu de cas similaires parce que 88 il
manquait une quinzaine de députés à
Michel Rocard pour former une majorité
au Parlement et aujourd'hui moi ce que
je vois c'est que il y a des attitudes
qui parfois
tentent vers le désordre vers
je dirais ce bordel généralisé
excusez-moi ça peut paraître vulgaire à
la bordélisation ça a été un terme qui a
été employé par d'autres courants je ne
pense pas que ça serve notre démocratie
parlementale notre démocratie
est quand même premier de la classe sur
cette question et le revendique vous
avez eu la commission des affaires
sociales la semaine dernière qui était
un champ de bataille
de démocratures en fait un mélange de
démocratie et puis de dictature
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez bah je
leur réponds que leurs collègues et les
filles ont aussi des attitudes un peu
excessives et glissement ça effrait les
Français et que c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire hier à votre place Olivier
fort le premier secrétaire du PS disait
qu'il n'allait plus siéger dans le
groupe de travail sur les institutions
il a dit je cite je ne vais pas
continuer à faire le guignol avec des
gens qui me prennent pour un con
que dites-vous encore une fois vous
voyez c'est je préférais le temps de
François Mitterrand les débats étaient
un peu plus élevés
la mobilisation mardi vous l'avez
constaté était en net refus mais le
soutien des Français envers les
manifestations reste forts et
l'opposition reste promette de ne rien
lâcher est-ce que vous redoutez pas que
cette réforme s'apparente ou au
sparadrap du capitaine Haddock et
qu'elle revienne via le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale vous via
des niches parlementaires
oui on parle de ça depuis tout à l'heure
il y a d'autres sujets c'est vrai que la
journée d'historique du 8 juin puisque
nous on l'a présenté comme une journée
historique tourne autour de ça
je pense vraiment que il y a il y a un
peu d'excès dans la manière de traiter
cette affaire de la part des oppositions
et que je pense que les Français vont
pas tarder à passer à autre chose si ce
n'est déjà fait justement en parlant
d'autres choses c'est vrai que là ces
derniers temps on est aux mi-temps des
100 jours ce temps donné par le par le
président pour relancer le quinquennat
c'est en bonne voie selon vous
on verra il y a un premier bilan qui
doit être fait par le Président de la
République le 14 juillet c'est lui qui a
déterminera si nous sommes on verra
au bout de 50 jours j'imagine que vous
avez quand même déjà une bonne idée non
j'ai déjà une idée de ce qui s'est passé
hier à l'Assemblée nationale il y a une
programmation militaire qui a été voté à
une très large majorité
pourtant parallèlement à cela vous avez
la journée parlementaire de l'iode qui
est focalise l'attention c'est pas rien
plusieurs milliards d'euros aux
centaines de milliards d'euros sont
préparés la défense 400 pour préparer la
défense de notre pays et il y a petite
guerre depuis un an aux frontières de
l'Europe
est-ce que aujourd'hui la sécurité des
Français elle a assuré on a eu un débat
construit sans outrance sans outrage
pour vous c'est bon c'est relancé on est
en train de passer à autre chose c'est
la démonstrée peut encore continuer à
travailler je vous rappelle que le jour
où le 49-3 était déclenché par Elisabeth
borne sur les retraites le jour même il
y avait un vote quasi unanime sur je ne
sais plus quel texte à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'on a passé des textes très
important pour notre environnement pour
notre énergie à des majorités très
larges que une loi de programmation pour
l'intérieur la locmi printemps est très
largement passée que nous avons eu des
débats construits sur des tas de sujets
moi je continue de penser que les
députés peuvent également travailler
dans de meilleures conditions et on a
démontré hier avec la loi de
programmation militaire
est-ce qu'il faut animer quand même pour
redynamiser ce quinquennat c'est pas moi
de décider vous savez il y a un
président de la République et une
première ministre
les remaniements sont décidés général
par les deux têtes de l'exécutif et
c'est quand
ils estiment nécessaire de le faire
qu'ils le font hier justement pendant la
loi de programmation militaire Sébastien
Lecornu mais il s'est armé était encensé
par toutes les oppositions louées pour
son sens de l'écoute du compromis les
oppositions qui lui disaient même qu'il
devait donner des leçons à Elisabeth
Borny frein à mon premier ministre c'est
un très bon ministre des Armées et c'est
un homme politique accompli bien que
jeune qui a déjà prouvé dans tous les
postes qu'il a occupé qu'il avait du
talent et beaucoup de savoir-faire donc
il est prêt pour bâtiment moi je suis
pas là pour faire la course au petit
show alors on va parler politique on va
parler immigration oui et des
propositions de la sortie des d'Edouard
Philippe que nous vous connaissez bien
et qui distille dans un entretien très
commenté à L'Express c'est ses
propositions sur l'immigration alors
vous permettrait de voir quand même que
ça arrive en concordance avec le moment
où Gérald Darmanin tente de trouver une
voie de passage avec les républicains et
que j'ai à Philippe Édouard Philippe
qualifie la le projet de loi de
nécessaire mais pas suffisant est-ce que
c'est pas un peu tirer contre son propre
camp vous avez d'abord je voudrais dire
que
Édouard Philippe a prévenu le ministre
de l'intérieur ils se sont vus qu'il
allait sortir ce sujet donc il y a pas
de de coup de jardin il y a pas de
mauvaise manière qui est faite et il a
également prévenu Olivier du soft parce
que je vous rappelle que c'était qu'au
porteur du projet gouvernemental
Edouard Philippe a beaucoup travaillé
sur la question et il considère
aujourd'hui que certes le texte le
projet proposé par le gouvernement à
Madame bon sens mais que si on veut
véritablement avancer sur la question de
l'immigration et également la question
des rapports avec la saison de pays
l'Algérie cela a été appelé la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et son article 8 qui pose à sa
tombe de problème c'est votre avis
également c'est à dire que vous aussi
vous êtes prêts à dire comme Édouard
Philippe que le projet de loi actuel est
nécessaire mais pas suffisant il ne
suffira pas il ne suffira pas pour
régler le problème tel qu'on voudra le
régler je vous renvoie à ce qu'a dit
Edouard Philippe lorsqu'il a fondé le
parti horizon il avait parlé de
plusieurs vertiges parmi les vertiges
dont il parlait il y avait les vertiges
démographiques et notamment se lier à
l'immigration incontrôlée féminine de
découvrir un certain nombre de choses
alors que elles sont dites depuis à
certains nombre de temps et aujourd'hui
ce texte il va dans le bon sens il va
dans le bon sens il améliore bien des
situations il va rendre nos politiques
plus efficaces mais il ne traitera pas
le mal à la racine à savoir les sujets
qu'a voulu développer Édouard Philippe
dans l'article donc vous êtes plutôt sur
la ligne des républicains il faut un
texte plus dur sur la ligne d'Édouard
Philippe je vous rappelle quand je suis
président
il va y avoir un projet de loi du
gouvernement et de sex horizons il y a
pas de textes horizon comment vous
comptez porter dans un détournement de
la réalité
les propositions
et surtout pour que ceux qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien ce que je vais
dire et dans Philippe a dit nous
soutenons le texte
et nous voterons le texte proposé par le
gouvernement le gouvernement il a dit il
s'est permis de dire il y a des mesures
qui n'y figurent pas d'ailleurs elles ne
peuvent pas figurer d'un steak parce
qu'on est plus sur des étrangères que
sur un texte législatif qui devrait être
apporté si on voulait véritablement
s'attaquer au problème de l'immigration
tel qu'il se présente aujourd'hui et je
ne vois pas pourquoi est-ce que cela me
rapprocherait plus des LR que du
gouvernement
des républicains ont été déposés donc ça
veut dire qu'elles vont être débattues
que vous allez voter tu est-ce que vous
pourriez aller voter je ne sais pas
quand est-ce que ces lois seront
débattues peut-être même que le texte du
Gouvernement sera débattu avant
c'est
vous avez un texte qui devrait être
débattu a priori avant celui DLR donc
nous verrons bien que mes chaussures et
puis je ne désespère pas à un moment
qu'on soit en capacité de construire
ensemble un texte
je fais pas de mystère sur le fait qu'il
fallait trouver des majorités
s'approche de l'autre et rapproche ses
points de vue pour pouvoir rendre les
choses efficaces et toi Philippe dans
cette interview entre autres il défend
une remise en cause de l'accord de 68
avec l'Algérie qui accorde des règles
dérogatoire au droit commun pour la
circulation le séjour et le travail des
ressortissants algériens Gérard Larcher
hier a dit qu'il soutenait cette
proposition elle est députés les
républicains préparent une proposition
de résolution pour dénoncer cet accord
est-ce que l'ensemble du groupe horizon
la votera vous savez on va essayer
d'être cohérent si cette résolution
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale un débat
et qu'elle est dans l'état d'esprit qui
a été celui Édouard Philippe dans
l'interview de L'Express il y a pas de
raison que nous soyons sur un double ou
un triple discours
encore une fois vous savez
cette initiative elle ne peut venir que
du sommet c'est à dire de la présidence
de la République du gouvernement on
parle d'un traité international et ça se
prépare je remarque que aujourd'hui
effectivement il y a ce traité qui pose
question et il y a également
l'application l'interprétation de
certains traités notamment celui de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et de son article 8 qui pose des
questions alors en revanche hier soir
les républicains ils vous ont reproché
un double discours sur la question de
l'AM de l'aide médicale d'État parce que
dans son interview d'avoir Philippe dit
qu'il faut s'interroger sur les
modalités de la me pour lutter contre
des abus choquants c'est ce qu'il dit et
hier soir les députés de la majorité
dont horizon ont voté contre une
proposition des républicains qui visait
à restreindre cet ame elle a recentré
sur les seuls soins urgents est-ce que
c'est pas contradictoire
on connaît leur projet donc ils étaient
pour la suppression de la mute tel
qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui dans
l'article que vous citez le fameux
article dit qu'il faut pas la supprimer
pourquoi je vais vous expliquer très
simplement
la mu c'est pas que
d'air comme dit le dis certains pour
l'immigration médicale la mue c'est pour
protéger les Français il y a des
épidémies qui peuvent faire mal je crois
qu'on a quand même une idée de la
question après la covid-19 vous savez
que
de pas soigner quelqu'un qui est malade
ça peut avoir des conséquences sur la
santé publique d'un pays tout entier et
ne pas également financer l'hôpital
public parce que une personne en
situation irrégulière elle ne paye pas
ses soins
je vous rappelle quand même que le
déficit de l’hôpital public c'est pas
une petite affaire dans le pays donc moi
je pense qu'il faut essayer d'avoir des
arguments raisonnables sur cette
question on n'a pas voté la résolution
parce qu'elle n'était pas écrite d'une
manière qui était de nature à nous
convaincre en revanche en revanche oui
probablement en revanche en revanche
revoir les paniers de soins
réévaluer les situations pour qu'elles
soient considérées comme plus juste par
les Français et efficace Édouard
Philippe l'a fait lorsqu'il était
Premier ministre en 2019 et il faut le
refaire le cas échéant ça veut dire
qu'il faut redescreindre parce que en
effet vous avez raison de le rappeler en
2019 elle avait déjà été cette aide
contrainte et là il faut encore plus la
contraindre si le besoin ça fait sentir
oui moi je suis pas spécial je ne
connais pas les dépenses sur une année
budgétaire concernant la même et
j'aimerais bien avoir le détail je ne
pense pas qu'on parle de milliards
d'euros
on va parler de la Corse puisque on le
disait un hier les discussions ont
repris donc entre Gérald Darmanin et les
élu Corse à Beauvau le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui attend désormais des
propositions des élus de l'île c'est ce
qu'il vous a dit est-ce qu'une unanimité
peut se dégager entre le corps sur la
question de l'autonomie je sais pas je
sais pas si c'est souhaitable
en revanche moi ce que je ferais vous
allez lui présenter à géraldman pendant
quelques semaines moi je vais lui
présenter mes propositions personnelles
je suis parlementaire j'ai une réflexion
personnelle sur la question je travaille
avec des spécialistes j'ai rappelé hier
qu'avant la fin du mois de juin ou
peut-être début du mois de juillet je
ferai des propositions donc chacun vous
vous ferez les vôtres Jean Simon fera
les siennes il y aura pas de position
commune et si elles étaient proches les
unes des autres et qu'on arrivait à
trouver à un moment une voix de passage
c'est souhaitable c'est ce que j'ai
rappelé hier moi je souhaiterais le
consensus le plus large possible c'est
toujours comme ça que ça s'est passé
lorsqu'on a fait des avancées notamment
institutionnelles au niveau de la Corse
mais encore une fois vous en doutez
pas que j'en doute mais mais peut-être
qu'on peut être aussi en désaccord sans
pour autant s'échapper et surtout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'on respecte une
forme de cadre qui a été fixée dès 2017
et qui a été rendu impossible parce que
la réforme constituelle de 2018 a été
abandonnée c'est inscrire la Corse dans
la Constitution la dotée d'un
fonctionnement qui lui ressemble qui ne
soit pas celui d'un autre ou d'une autre
région c'est quoi le fonctionnement qui
lui ressemble et justement on doit le
créer ensemble mais c'est quoi être une
composition dans le cadre de la
République avec des responsabilités qui
lui soit propres avec le fait d'affirmer
que il y a pas de dérive
indépendantistes pour l'avenir avec le
fait également de lui donner des
compétences pour pouvoir gérer à cet
homme de problèmes qu'elle Gérard
probablement mieux si elle en est dotée
aller plus loin sur la question de
l'autonomie c'est pas un gros mot moi je
l'ai toujours dit
un statut un peu à la polynésienne et
justement vous voyez ça vient en
contradiction moi je pense que avec une
île de méditer qui est à 45 minutes de
Nice à 1h30 de Paris en avion on peut
avoir un statut qu'on appelle suit
generises qui sera le seul parce qu'il
sera le sien et pas celui d'un autre et
pas faire des copies et je pense que
nous avons démontré dans l'histoire
constitutionnelle française qu'on
pouvait s'adapter et c'est là que la
République est forte c'est leur qu'elle
est en capacité de s'adapter à une
situation donnée un territoire de 350
000 habitants une montagne dans la mer
comme on le dit avec des problématiques
économiques spécifiques avec une
histoire avec une identité comme
l'ensemble de nos territoires et avec
surtout une volonté d'être écouté d'être
entendu parce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
l'agression du petit Kenzo samedi soir
lors du match entre la C Ajaccio et l'OM
à choqué à ému enfin de sa famille
l'agression de sa famille à Choquet ému
est-ce que vous en savez plus sur ce qui
s'est passé précisément il y a une
enquête qui est en cours il y a des
vidéos surveillance qui sont à
disposition de la justice et les
personnes qui ont agressé l'ont fait un
visage découvert moi je m'en remets au
parquet d'Ajaccio et à la justice
sentiment quand même par rapport à cette
idée à faire comment voulez-vous sortir
et moi je suis père de famille je vois
un petit garçon malade qui plus est être
dans une telle situation ça crève le
cœur et j'ai même aller plus loin vous
savez il y a une violence dans le pays
aujourd'hui à peu près à tous les états
civilisations dont on dont on parle dans
le président parlait et en tout cas il y
a un problème il y a un problème Orange
Mécanique moi je dis à chaque fois il y
a de la violence gratuite et ultra et
c'est pas que dans les stades de foot
vous le voyez dans la rue vous le voyez
pour des places de parking vous le voyez
l'un des commerces aujourd'hui les gens
certaines personnes en tout cas ne
reculent devant rien et certainement pas
devant la violence aveugle géraldar
Manin hier à Beauvau a dit que la
sécurité dans le stade relevait des
organisateurs est-ce qu'il y a eu des
manquements de la part de la C1 moi je
me permettrai pas de dire ça en tout cas
là c'est à le club subit
faut pas mettre la c.a sur le banc des
accusés il subit des comportements de ce
type la ville d'Ajaccio subit et je
dirais l'accord c'est le football et le
pays subit aujourd'hui des violences
sont inacceptables comme ce qui s'est
passé à Bordeaux lorsqu’un joueur de
Rodez marque un but et qu'il a agressé
par un supporter où allons-nous que
fait-on pour pouvoir lutter contre ça
lorsque vous avez présidé la commission
d'enquête sur l'agression à mortelle
divan colonne qui a conclu à de graves
défaillances est-ce que vous avez fait
29 propositions est-ce que Gérald
Darmanin ou Éric Dupond-Moretti vous ont
informé d'une suite à donner assez à vos
propositions pas encore pas encore
d'abord je voudrais saluer l'état
d'esprit dans lequel ça s'est dérouler
ou parler de député le saveur que le
président de la commission et
Jean-Philippe aquaviv et qu'il est à
député l'iode ça s'est très bien passé
il y a eu un consensus qui s'est fait et
tous les députés ont votent à uneanimité
vous voyez qu'on peut travailler à
l'Assemblée nationale du RN à LFI les
propositions faites par ce rapport et ce
rapport en lui-même ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on on soit là pour apaiser la
situation parce que la Corse elle a
besoin d'apaisement qu'on éclaire sur ce
qui s'est passé le 2 mars le plus
largement qu'on éclaire sur notre
système pénitentiaire qui a des
défaillances graves qui provoquent
parfois la mort de détenus ou même de
surveillants faut soutenir les
surveillants et c'est ce que je dis
aussi dans le rapport et qu'il faut
prendre en charge la radicalisation d'un
certain nombre de détenus et prévenir un
certain nombre de choses qui a pas été
le cas et et ce que je voudrais
également c'est qu'on avance pour la
Corse parce que ce qui s'est passé cette
maison d'arrêt c'est une centrale ça a
fait beaucoup de mal à la Corse mais
vous pensez que ça va avancer vous
pensez que le gouvernement va vous
écouter je continuerai de défendre cette
option et je ferai tout ce qui est on a
quelques calendriers et puis le rapport
est tout frais il vient de sortir il
faut le laisser vivre en dehors de sa
présentation une petite question sur la
la proposition de loi de votre collègue
Frédéric valthou on en parlait à
l'instant contre les déserts médicaux
elle sera débattue dans l'hémicycle la
semaine prochaine il y a certains
députés notamment socialistes Guillaume
Garraud qui plaide pour aller plus loin
dans la contrainte d'installation des
médecins libéraux qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ce sera débattu c'est un débat
qu'on a dans tous les groupes tous les
groupes à horizon vous avez des députés
qui veulent aller plus loin sur les
contraintes et d'autres qui considèrent
qu'il faut pas le faire et vous alors
quel est votre moi je soutiens ce qui a
été présenté par Frédéric Valtou c'est
pas une contrainte extrême parce qu'on a
essayé de travailler en concertation
avec le gouvernement qui lui-même essaye
aussi de travailler en concertation avec
les médecins c'est de voies de passage
qui sont parfaitement étroites vous le
savez il y a des refus parfois très
forts chez les professeurs médicales
donc ça se fait complexe j'aimerais
qu'il soit traité à la hauteur et même
si on n'est pas d'accord surtout qu'on
puisse en débattre sereinement que ce
soit pas un dommage collatéral de la
réforme des retraites concrètement
écoutez la possibilité moi je salue le
travail qui a été fait par Frédéric
Valtou dans la lignée de Thomas Meunier
sur cette question merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin la Une
de La Voix du Nord Julien la région
soumise aux quatre vents tout à fait
c'est la belle Une de La Voix du Nord ce
matin merci beaucoup nous a l'air le
cerveau d'avoir été avec nous merci
Laurent merci